hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to prison simulator ever
wanted to go to prison that's not what
this game is about this is where you're
going to discipline the prisoners that
are in your prison you got to make sure
that they don't kill you apparently
welcome to the prisoner creator here you
can choose in the appearance of your
convicts
on the right there are options to
customize your i love this
i love this
hi no ivan this is crongo that's congols
i love him this is crongo okay
how do i go back oh man i thought i
wasn't going to get it in the first time
all right
uh-huh
i almost don't want to change him ah wow
this is plumbing uh plumbing gordon all
right locked
you know they're perfect you know i
don't really have to do anything about
it
[Music]
i love these guys
perfect
[Music]
all right we got our we've got our
prisoners i'm actually shocked in the
gang creator you choose who joins one of
the three gangs you can
oh man there's a lot of customization
uh squirrels fox's beers
all right go for it whoa
well that's not a squirrel that's not a
fox
and let's go back to the
all right we got the
squirrels get the foxes look at the
bears okay i'm ready game automatically
saves at the end of the day i'm gonna
need a lot more saves than that because
i'm not gonna do well on this i can
already say that right now i'm not gonna
do well i'm gonna get murdered
immediately main task is to carry out
the routines assigned to you for the day
check their list in the journal jay
during their day react to the prisoners
bad behavior either by talking to them
or by using force and between routines
you can use your free time to enjoy the
fun of it
most of your actions are evaluated by
other guards and prisoners which affects
your level of respect the overall level
of respect bottom left corner is the
average of your individual relationships
with the prisoners during your free time
you can relax by playing minigames or
doing side quests more of these
activities will be available in the
future okay cool
all right i don't have a lot of respect
i'll take this
excuse me
hates wrinkles dunkel i mean i get that
man
good old wrinkles reporting for duty
relax call me dick we're on duty but we
don't stick to yes sirs that much
are you holding up feeling the pressure
of your first day of work
a little bit
there's nothing to worry about you'll
feel right at home here i can guarantee
that just like all the prisoners feel
like this is right at home for them
by the way on the first day of work
everyone has a meeting with the warden
and he expects the same from
you the warden you say
is this happy trails penitentiary
not really check the map or if you
change something your settings you have
to find it by yourself you know what
this is
suddenly keep your eyes
peeled to prison
through something that's going on in the
prison i don't know exactly what watch
yourself okay enough of that come on
follow me okay
this seems important employees of the
month oh
most contraband found oh
hi hello
hello sir i mean kenneth since we're
good friends
new guy
how good to see you it's how do you like
it here
[Music]
oh where's the toilet uh you got some
songs of your murder that's so [ __ ]
hilarious that's the funniest thing i've
heard all day you'll find it you're a
big boy
moving on what was i talking about
it's very good to be honest we're having
a lucky streak high subsidies the
prisoners are content and there are no
currently outstanding issues from my
duties you will have plenty of them but
let's start with what you're doing today
let me look at the documents today you
have a longer shift get a new prisoner
take care of them check all documents
everything you can if they're legit send
them off to a cell block keep your eyes
on the boy in the yard block b can
really stir [ __ ] up so be careful in the
afternoon a new delivery of items from
the prisoner's relatives arrives inspect
them you can't even imagine what their
wives try to smuggle
understand don't interrupt me i finally
get it okay
rude need ever make sure they don't [ __ ]
around we need every penny we can make
to renovate the prison buy new equipment
take a break drink some coffee and work
out with the guys at the gym or
something
everything i almost forgot go to the
guys in the guards room in the afternoon
they'll instruct you on some skills that
are worth knowing while you're here
okay you can go you have a lot to do oh
i do
okay go to the search room okay
i'm fast
i am so
speedy okay committing new prisoners to
start accepting prisoners call the
waiting person with the microphone check
the fingerprints name and id number if
everything's okay confirm the document
otherwise reject the application the
application
the application to the prison to be a
prisoner they gotta apply search other
prisoners without blurs no belongings
take out a bliss and black all the items
also remember to blurt the blizzard
himself okay cool
oh
carefully check every single item for
contraband okay
basically welcome to prison welcome to
welcome to prison hey
how do i get rid of this goddamn
hey hey
whoa
all right
this is a bit much all right let's let's
tone it down a bit no no no let's tone
it down listen hey hey hey hey hey come
on come on i'm i apologize i apologize i
apologize i apologize can i get some
help
i can't leave without a rush
help me he's trying to kill me
oh
ow
this god there's no cleave damage
reject him reject him
reject you're rejected very violent
please leave me alone
please
please oh my god i'm gonna die
to attack [ __ ] assign oh
all right um okay here we go
wow he's good
okay and uh one for good measure
okay um oh he's getting up he's
resisting bang
okay well oh god sorry you were you were
i apologize
all right yeah get out of here get out
of here get out of here
get out of here
get out of here all right that went well
next hey how's it going friend how you
doing
all right that's a little rude okay a
little aggressive
okay
looks like fingerprints are all matched
up there block a that's great leo just
check compliance
correctness of the name data okay leo
jones
409025 american
looks good
wait a minute there's a discrepancy oh
wait no that's just when they were taken
never mind um
looks good to me approved um
[Laughter]
okay check the person's belongings okay
what are your belongings what is this
heart pills for broken hearts and other
heart problems i don't know if i believe
that but
man let's open the item
okay if you search everything from the
list all right that looks like pills i
guess
all right searching
searching
[Music]
okay
well i think we're all done here
hold after i just did
take the supplies for a prisoner by
pressing e and also give him
with the key there you go
all right
[Music]
all right be nice be good
i did it i uh did my job well when you
know someone has an exclamation point i
do not want to take a quest from this
guy no offense to this guy's face but
this guy's face is insulting to my
existence all right good i did it i did
a thing
hello nap i could nap i don't want to
nap i don't want to work out
what's the gun icon do what do we have
here the shooting range
what is this what is that
is that my hand
is that what it looks like clean weapon
okay disassemble a weapon and clean it
that's a strange thing to have in this
game
what
what i see
okay i disassembled what is
what
okay i'll start with this i guess
splash
it's like the uh the uh freaking uh
excavation grave robbing game it's just
like that i'm not sure if this is doing
anything
okay
i'm gonna rub this whoa that's a rub
okay that's clean i think
swabbies
i'm swapping i'm swarming i swabbed it i
don't understand what i'm swapping oh oh
oh oh oh my god okay all right i really
came in here for shooting something i
feel like i've been extremely lied to
this is nowhere near as satisfying as
power washing simulator i will give it
that much
okay well that was great good job boy i
can't wait to do the next part
here i go i guess
[Music]
done
squiggity squeaky squeak
well that was great that was good stuff
[Music]
excellent let me shove a rod down in
this thing
[Music]
d s-a-s-s-s-w-d-d
w w d
d w a a a
d
a s w s
d a double okay
[Applause]
and rag
done
look at that bad boy put that bad boy on
that bad boy and then this bad boy there
and that bad boy then that bad boy do i
get to shoot it now
hey a gun
okay let's
we'll see when those unruly prisoners
get a little uppity with me
bang bang bang
bang
that one guy had a thick skull
a clock i mean that's kind of fun not
gonna lie kind of fun i mean i did
terribly but
not gonna lie kind of fun i haven't been
doing a lot of prison handling i haven't
really been like prisonating anything i
feel like i'm doing all the wrong you
know what i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna exit
this activity because i have not
i've not been doing what i need to do
which is like go to the prison yard
i forget i'm forgetting my true purpose
here
which is to
manage the prisoners of which i'm off to
a bad start oh yes please i need that
thank you can i have some nachos
this is exactly how i heal myself nachos
inventory inventory nachos eat eat eat
eat okay i'm not showed up i did not
heal at all hey what's going on guys on
the prison yard your main task is to
look for suspicious situations react
accordingly warning direct force
disciplinary punishment paying attention
to inappropriate behavior and other
infractions like sneaking fighting
suspicious behaviors destroying property
or urinating
no pissing in my yard if it's calm
enough you can relax but there's a
chance you won't notice the wrong
situations pay attention to the time to
end the routine properly you'd have to
let the prisoners be outside for the
minimum in time if you let them stay
longer your respect level will increase
okay
spitting on you
well you're not
you look quite okay maybe you want to
get some money hmm
depends on what you want as i know
packages will come to the prison
tomorrow and you check what's inside is
it possible to turn a blind eye to one
package there would be a needle let's
say i really need everything from this
package i'll reward you of course
i'm so sorry there's no free ride ah
what's the worst could happen great take
half now 25 and again when the package
will be in my hands everything what i
need hey how's it going
hey you good
you can improve your statistics i don't
even know what my statistics are
hi what's up
want to play play what
prisoners is
what walkie talkie
am i fighting bet with timed barbell
lists
15 times
hey hey hey
[Music]
that's what you get that's what you get
that's what you get puro hey whoa whoa
wait schmongo oh yeah wait no you are
you the guy that i
alright yeah yeah yeah you better you
better watch yourself you better watch
yourself you better watch yourself i'm
watching you
i'm watching you you better watch
yourself
okay i don't know
50 bucks 50 bucks says i can't okay
okay alternate
too too fast what do you mean too fast
what do you mean too fast
what
come on
okay i know i got it i got it
i don't have time for injured prisoners
right now i'm doing a push-up con a
bench press contest it's very important
that i win 50 bucks on the line i do not
get paid enough to deal with not winning
get out of my way i am going to win this
come on come on come on
i did it i win
i won respect me
you respect me crongo you respect me huh
what about you george who the hell is
george okay well first day man
i did good i feel good i am good
i am justice in this place
fair
beautiful
brown is there anything that can help me
heal
heals 700 hp a nut bar give me a goddamn
nut bar
oh hell yeah nut me up
okay
i'm nutted
a briefing room oh hey
how's it going barry
already are we done for today
yes it's over oh i made money and i got
respects
that's pretty impressive i did it i d
that was the most horrible first day
that i ever could have and yet i still
got respect that's how good i am at this
job all right day two hey what's up
scott
all right bye scott
hey
what's up my bros you wanna play some
darts you know i do
i don't know what uh what is baseball
i don't just give me some money uh
okay i don't know what this is all about
miss what do you mean miss what is
baseball
runs number on the board that
corresponds to the current inning
oh
what
[Music]
what what
perfect there we go
[Music]
this is my jam this is my chance
this is my chance this is my time to
shine
this is my time to shine i've whoa yeah
what are you going for the oh you're
going for the bullseye there idiot
what's stupid you being stupid the
answer is yes
ah this is my time to shine
okay now i've got it
took me a second to get there but now i
got it and i'm absolutely crushing you
in every way possible
you're gonna be so embarrassed to go
home to your wife and tell her how bad
you lost
all right once again i feel like i have
not been doing much in the way of actual
prison aiding donut
hello
uh ready to learn some tricks from us
do they teach anything other than
beating prisoners more effectively i'd
be careful with such jokes especially in
the presence of prisoners they're
nothing more than skills that will help
you survive in here which by the way
should be very useful presenters are
twitchy try to solve conflicts by
talking first i can teach you but you
need two things first skill points and
money feel skill points every time you
level up and you level up after you gain
some experience each day when you're at
certain level you have enough skill
points and of course the right money you
can buy a skill which will help you do
your job better and more easily
yes i think you're going to get you're
ready to get your first skill
how much does it cost first one's on the
house it'll cost you only a skill point
which you should have at least one by
now because you're new and you should be
getting a little more sense right away
we'll start from the very beginning see
for yourself
searching intimidating search 25 faster
i don't even know where the cells are
i've never even seen this set what what
cells all i've done is i shoot gun play
darts and i lifted some weights
sounds like i'm at a bar hello
ah right package search ah
harmless marmless herder
interesting okay let's take a look at
this shibbity whoop forget me not
very famous author eh uh-huh
okay
[Music]
oh what is this
what is this
okay
i'm going to take it
oh i t i meant to oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh what is this what is this drugs
let's see what is in here candy
i'm taking that all right
we've done it checked
i think
uh okay oh my god toothpaste huh okay
okay
chicken tits okay
oh
no no no mine
okay stone peeling
okay i mean to be honest if the worst is
just there's a joint in here it's not
it's not the worst thing in the world
but at the same time
can't have it on my watch very strict
around here very strict
okay what do we have candy nice
nice
oh look would you look at that
i'm gonna leave that there
oh there's another what is
my god okay leaving the needles
apparently
oh hi
damn there's a lot of needles
this is just a lot of needles my guys
there's a lot of needles all right good
i did it
okay what for what's the problem over at
least one responsible person in this
[ __ ] some jerk lost prison keys and
not just one pair of them take a quick
stroll around and find the [ __ ] as soon
as you can before some prisoner finds it
don't slack off we don't have much time
okay um
what do i do about that hello oh well
that's candy
oh no one would have found that we were
totally fine the whole time
you had me panicked for nothing
wait oh there's more that oh my god how
many keys okay no never mind some people
are dumb as hell this is a problem
hey what's up
didn't really think you would succeed
maybe talk time just look after your
[ __ ] talking to an officer watch your
tone overnight wait damn you found our
you found four pairs of keys right no i
only found three i'm [ __ ] pairs
missing probably one of those idiots
lost somewhere back at work
okay yeah i'll forget about that yeah
it's not a big deal
what's up brian
oh this is nice
oh be careful with that
oh here are the cells
oh interesting
hey what's up flint
better go and check where you should be
i don't know where i should be i have
free time
you want to get one in the snout uh you
know i'm okay thank you this is actually
pretty good honestly like
i kind of went into this being more
jokey because you know you never know
what's gonna happen but honestly it's
this isn't bad it's surprisingly
detailed there's a lot going on here
what was this
oh i think this is where the entrance is
yeah i can see how you could definitely
make a whole routine of going through
this place and taking care of the
prisoners stopping riders all that stuff
this is kind of fun anyway where's p-o-e
anybody saying p-o-e
basketball okay
five hoops in a minute okay let's go 50.
oh timer's on now
oh god oh god timer's on
one
oh i gotta stay behind the free throw
line
one
for
all the throwing of things in uh
all the throwing of things in um
paranormal perperon pepper
poltergeist para
i really can't remember what the name of
it was
fantasma phobia fan
phantasmophobia phantasmophobia go to
the cell block evening attendance oh
okay
all the throwing of things into the
thing from anyway hey what's going on
man i gotta work on my stamina hey
what's going on in here oh you pooping
okay
uh sorry
you'd be pooping at that moment
this routine is a little different from
the morning one now you have to make
sure all the prisoners return to their
cells they should be in front of them as
soon as you show up use the clicker to
cross the prisoner off the list
somebody isn't standing under his cell
and just walks around bring him out it's
best to remind him who's charge all
right
get ready i was wondering what this is
for
all right plum b all right that's good
you're good
all right we got krungo over here we got
pee oi
hey i got uh all right good yeah krungo
you're good
uh we got puro
we got sug nut
[Music]
all right you get to your freaking thing
all right merfathu okay we got smungo
good we got a marmless herder
what are you doing stew
man
you got a job
okay you go yourself
try me stooch
[Music]
yeah that's what you get
what are you doing crongo
what are you doing
yeah you better get to yourself chrono
i'm telling you one thing you gotta get
in there immediately pen
what the hell happened here holy [ __ ]
chrongo you get in your cell right now i
don't want to hear a single excuse
all right good job guys well done
everybody
well disciplined people
beautiful people actually you sleep good
you sleep good you sleep good you all
sleep good
hello hi how you doing
done for the day yeah i'm done
that's a lot of lost respect probably
because i beat the ever loving [ __ ] out
of the prisoners i don't know how to be
nicer i'm not a nice guy
so it kinda is difficult
oh [ __ ]
reporter for duty
with the riot whole prison but
call for help next take a look around go
the yard try to get some of these idiots
to stand down what about weapons what
you expect me to do
[Applause]
okay what's next find the keys
we're short you're not invincible
there's death in those corridors if you
lose consciousness one is nice but
trying to get yourself killed okay
okay oh boy oh boy okay so i did i keep
that all right let's get the
taser out first try to be no no no no no
no no no you go you go
hey stop it
zai said stop it i've been pepper
sprayed before you don't want it you
don't want it
all right do i have handcuffs do i have
anything to no i don't okay
all right you stay down
oh my god where's my fire extinguisher
holy [ __ ]
this is kind of nuts
[Music]
why do i gotta put out all the fires
why is this my job and but i mean it's
awesome and i like it but
why is it my job and holy hell they
rioted like
like nobody's business i didn't know
that riot meant zombie apocalypse here
some of the doors in prison can become
damaged pick the lock
i gotta pick a lock
[Music]
oh it's just like cleaning
perfect
easy
boink
doink
doink easy
easiest thing in the world
oh my god what the hell
why did i want to go in here
oh here we go
rioting i'm gonna see if they destroy
what's the situation it's hard to say
fire and chaos
okay thank you all right i gotta get
this prison yard under control
and that means one thing
my riot gun
[Music]
don't make me i'm gonna pepper spray the
[ __ ] out of you
christopher robinson how could you hey
hey
hey watch it don't even think about it
down on the ground wham
okay okay okay okay okay
yep
that's what you get right in the nog all
right i gotta get this oh i gotta get
this situation under control i'm gonna
pepper spray everybody what's it hey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wow wow come on
i don't want to shoot you but i might
okay you're all down that's good that's
good that's good look you got to respect
me for being able to take all of you
guys down right you guys respect that
right
oh my god
i hope it's a rubber bullet hey
run the dick
it is it must be it seems like a rubber
bullet hey
no no
no
no no no
stop it stop it
hey you stop it right i gotta put this
i guess
good
was this because i let that guy have
needles
i think it might be because i let that
guy have needles i don't think this is
gonna put
something tells me this ain't gonna put
why is there like artillery strikes
happening can i put this out at least
no
that's okay i didn't want it anyway all
right time to shoot more people in the
face
oh wait i missed something here
i thought i already cleared out the
canteen
ah keys of course
ah
sorry bud
hey trying to ambush me
it shan't work
bang boom
i gotta admit the gun play is pretty
good here
i'm kind of surprised
god i hope these are just rubber bullets
hello
boinkpoint hey you guys are my guys
no you're not who are you
what happened to my dudes
ah they're too well behaved for this
they would never
never in a million years all right i
gotta take over the workshop they were
so nice in the workshop are you telling
me that they're riding in the workshop
but they were lovely
they were absolutely delightful
hey
no
all right it's time to go back to what
he's got a weapon
that's a lot of people who wants some
that's right help me buddy
no not the counter i want to count how
many times i'm going to whap you in the
skull
there we go easy wow
not on my watch baby not on my watch
looks like uh
justice has been served were you just
standing here the whole time
you did well the boys from the assault
team are on their way want to call for
transport and end the day or do you want
to search the prison a little bit more
i'm tired let's end this say
i shot a lot of prisoners
oops all right so that is uh person
simulator prologue just the demo this
game isn't fully out yet but there's a
lot of potential here there actually is
like normally with things like this it's
always kind of janky even if those other
games that i played were like they had
mechanics in there but this one's got
mechanics and also like intricacies to
it that's very nice i like that
i like it
i like it it's about as close as i want
to get to prison but i like it it's not
bad so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to check out other
simulator games that i've played there's
links in the description or probably if
you look at the suggested videos over
there-ish you can find more on my
channel
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you